We Begin five headlines exactly where
you expected us to begin with the UFO
hearings on Capitol Hill the historic
hearings actually historic
in this case they really are historic
daily wire reports lawmakers held an
explosive hearing on Wednesday on the
topic of UFOs and things got well weird
appearing before the house oversight
committees National Security
subcommittee was David grush a Former
Intelligence officer along with two
fighter pilots with first-hand
unidentified aerial phenomenon
experiences grush was the star revealing
an alleged top secret multi-decade crash
retrieval and reverse engineering
program only to be denied access and
accusing the military of
misappropriating funds
gross dropped a bombshell about aircraft
with non-human Origins complete with
biologics recovered from these
mysterious crafts
lawmakers from both sides of the aisle
are now scratching their heads wondering
how in the world or Beyond it they
should proceed with these astonishing
claims
um well we have rather than read of the
article I suppose we have some of these
clips and I mean I prefer to play the
whole hearing it'd be worth our time but
I can't really do that so I have to boil
this down to like two or three moments
that I think are the most important so
we'll start here with representative
Nancy Mays questioning uh Mr grush
and here's how that one watch
do you believe our government has made
contact with intelligent
extraterrestrials
it's something I can't discuss in public
setting
um okay and I can't ask when you think
this occurs if you believe we have
crashed craft uh stated earlier do we
have the bodies of the pilots who
piloted this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program
now we're going to talk about that but I
want to play uh all these clips before
we talk so
here we have witnesses talking about the
technology and capabilities of the UFOs
and by the way again these are people
who personally witnessed
some of these crafts and not only
witnessed it but we also have video of
what they witnessed this is a fair
amount of evidence
um but here's what they say they move
essentially
ways in which current technology or
aircraft that we know of are unable to
actually function or move and so will
you just for the public record again
once once again
um just uh briefly uh just either
describe or note that aircraft that are
being witnessed particularly by the 30
folks that you're working with are
essentially outside the scope of
anything that we know of today in the
technology we have today Mr graves Mr
favor
yes the objects that are being seen by
commercial pilots are performing
Maneuvers that are unexplainable due to
our current understanding of our
technology and our capabilities as a
country and that applies for the
military as well Mr
yeah I concur with that we have nothing
that can stop in midair and go the other
direction nor do we have anything that
can like in our situation come down from
space hang out for three hours and go
back up thank you my last question and
so and sometimes you I know that some
you have also said some of these answers
in the past we're trying to get them on
the public record as well which is
really important Mr gresh finally do you
believe that our government is in
possession of uaps
absolutely based on interviewing uh over
40 Witnesses over four years and and
where
I know the exact locations
okay so these are so one thing we hear
the the people
who want to dis dismiss what grush is
saying they'll they'll claim well he did
witness any of this but of course if he
said he witnessed it the same people
would say well we don't trust him I
don't believe so like no matter what he
said it would make a difference to them
uh well you do have flanking him though
on either side are people who did
witness some things and it's not like
those who are skeptical of grush and say
he did witness it it's not like they are
listening to the other two and saying
well I believe them so again
if you're starting from the position
that all of this is somehow impossible
or you refuse to believe it then there
is nothing anyone could ever say
and there is no evidence anyone could
ever present that you would find
compelling and there are a lot of people
in that camp and if you're in that camp
at least admit it at least admit that
it's just rather than saying I don't try
the evidence is it's not enough evidence
no there is no evidence that you would
find compelling because in this case we
have we have videos of eyewitness
testimony we have we have um
you know uh and as eyewitness testimony
from all kinds of different people right
actual expert eyewitness testimony but
expert I don't mean expert in the sense
that we hear trust the experts but
experts as in Navy pilots who understand
how aircraft work and they it's their
whole job to go up and identify
um things that are happening in the sky
and potential threats and all that so
like actual experts in that sense we
have those kinds of witnesses we have
lots of normal people who've seen so
when you've got video when you've got I
I witness testimony
um that's
that's evidence and there's a lot of
both of those things
finally
have there been any uh non-human
Technologies or or you know uh
interactions that have caused harm to
humans that was a question that was
asked and let's
let's hear
so there has been activity by by alien
or
non-human technology and or beings that
has caused harm to
humans uh I can't get into the specifics
in an open environment but at least the
activity that I personally witnessed and
have to be very careful here because you
don't you know they tell you never to
acknowledge tradecraft right so what I
personally witness myself and my wife
was very disturbing
okay now a few things here first if you
cannot at least appreciate the fact that
we're having this Congressional hearing
about non-human technology in the sky
then I don't know what to say you know
there are a bunch of people on social
media yesterday that I saw that were
they were saying this is all boring it's
boring I'm so bored
my God you dull nitwits really this
subject is boring
I've seen the subjects that you people
find interesting okay I've seen the
kinds of things that that you people
talk about for days on end and this is
boring to you
compared to all the other things that
are discussed on social media every day
this is what you find boring
you've got these right-wing pundits I've
seen plenty of them go on for days and
days about the same damn thing repeating
the same talking points over and over
again just an insatiable appetite for
the most boring mundane dreary useless
conversation yet a congressional hearing
where a witness testifies to the
existence of non-human technology is
boring
even if you think it's all fake by the
way you could if you think it's all fake
it's still not boring like it's
interesting okay it's either way this is
easily the most interesting thing that's
happened in Washington DC maybe since
ever
so if what they're testifying to is true
that's fascinating if this is all some
kind of insane elaborate ruse
that's also fascinating um and certainly
worth talking about
so the it's boring stuff it blows my
mind I don't I just don't get it
I really don't
you know I love anything made with top
of the line quality and for meat that is
good ranchers the only thing missing is
a pork box well if you ask for it they
deliver good ranchers has just launched
their Prime pork 100 American pork that
is Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you'll get 30 off with my code
Walsh at goodrancers.com on their site
you can explore their All-American cuts
of prime pork prime beef better than
organic chicken options if you've tried
their beef and chicken before then you
know how amazing it is you have to try
this Prime pork at least once trust me
they've got genuinely great products and
top tier customer service so what are
you waiting for enjoy real meat and real
service today with with good ranchers
visit goodranchers.com use my code walls
for 30 off any box that's promo code
wallish at goodrancers.com good ranchers
American Meat delivered we're days away
from the Durbin Accords the greatest
threat to the US Dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd bricks stations are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities is
part of their long-term plan to supplant
America and the dollar has cornerstones
of the Global Financial system you can
protect your IRA or 401K from The
Fallout of this Landmark Announcement by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have well you can protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
you can find out why by texting Walsh to
989898 and get your free info kit on
gold of a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it'll be nice to have
some gold to depend on again text Walsh
to 989898
okay so then
that raises the question of whether or
not this is all fake like it and if it
is then why
and don't tell me it's a distraction
technique don't tell me that I've
already addressed that many times okay
uh you know what I'm gonna say
the claim that all this is one big
distraction it's one big um diversion
is simply nonsensical because first of
all it does not distract
nobody cares
they should but they don't so it is it
is not a it is not a successful
distraction technique
why would they keep doing it to distract
when it is actually not distracting
anybody okay this UFO hearing happened
it was trending sort of for a few hours
on Twitter and then it went away and no
one talked about it anymore
so and you're saying this is they're
doing all of this this is one giant
conspiracy to distract us
and what the people that are doing they
don't notice that it's not working and
they keep doing it
second as I've said many times they
don't need to make up aliens to distract
us we are already distracted we already
ignore most of the most important things
happening in the world we already move
on from things at the speed of light we
have the attention spans of Plankton
already
and third if the government would use
aliens to distract us why did they deny
all of this for decades
there was plenty that they would have
wanted to distract us from in the 50s
and 60s and 70s and 80s and 90s and
2000s and 2010s and yet they denied it
and I deny denied denied
and and then just out of nowhere they
decided to start uh distracting us with
this
even though it's not distracting
but it should
that brings me to my next point which is
that if your skepticism of government is
informing your view on this stuff which
I understand
then that should cause you to take the
UFO subject more seriously not less the
government has officially denied all of
this forever
and they still do these are
whistleblowers who are coming out okay
this these These are um and it's only a
few of them
the predominant government narrative
since forever
and still now is that there are no UFOs
we don't need to think about it nothing
to see here is what the government has
always said about all of this
and this is still basically their
their response they've they've obliquely
acknowledged a little bit of this now
only because they're forced to
um and we've seen you know recent
history has shown us many examples of
things that were
dismissed as conspiracy conspiracy
theories and crazy and not even worth
thinking about
um and then they turn out to be true
and then the same government officials
who denied all of it will turn around
and say oh you know maybe there's some
truth to that I don't know
it's not because the government decided
to start being us because their their
hand was forced
because the truth came out and they had
no choice but to they couldn't keep just
flat out denying it
so you could say well this is a big big
distraction
it's not distracting us at all but
that's what it is uh so that could be
your theory another theory is that
you know the theory to explain why did
they deny deny deny and now you know
we're getting hearings about it
another explanation is that they denied
and denied denied forever because they
could
because we didn't have the internet and
there was really no way if somebody saw
something uh there was no way
to prove it you know it was also for for
for many decades while this was going on
people weren't carrying cell phones
around their pockets and that sort of
thing
um
but now with modern technology and
modern communication uh we can start
seeing things and spreading information
in a way that we couldn't before and so
now they have no choice but to like at
least pretend to acknowledge some of
this I mean that's another way of
explaining
um the contrast and how these issues
have been handled
Now versus then
so
what does all this mean
it means first of all this is
interesting and not and if you're if you
don't find it interesting you should
you're just wrong you're wrong to not
find it interesting it's like
objectively wrong
and uh what is it what is it what does
it actually mean like what are the
origins of these uh these things that
are in the sky I don't know exactly but
there is enough evidence at a minimum to
say that like something is going on okay
these crafts that are in the sky that
can do things that to us seem impossible
that defy the laws of physics
like traveling at many hundreds of miles
of an hour an hour and then stopping on
a dime in the middle of the air and
changing direction that sort of thing
um
that is happening there are things in
the sky that are doing all of that
ends
what that means is that someone
possesses that technology and if you
don't even want to consider the
possibility that it could be
otherworldly then you're left with there
are governments on Earth
that have technology that defies the
laws of physics as we understand it and
our and our eons ahead of us in their
technological uh capabilities
which is also interesting if that's the
case it's not boring certainly not
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed